va tout de suite partir à Moscou
retrouver Jean Didier revoir notre
correspondant Jean Didier bonsoir alors
que les Européens on en parlait se
réunissent ce soir à Bruxelles ils
doivent décider de sanction la Russie
elle promet une réplique sévère à ses
sanctions européennes
pour juger et attendre de voir quels
seront les fêtes ces sanctions de façon
à adapter sa réaction qui ne sera pas
forcément symétrique alors si l'on se
base sur sa réponse de 2014 après
l'annexion de la Crimée et bien la
Russie avait décrété un embargo sur des
produits agricoles de l'Union européenne
en embargo qui est toujours en vigueur
aujourd'hui et si on examine les armes à
disposition de Vladimir Poutine actuelle
et bien celle qui viennent en première
esprit sont l'énergie et le gaz vous
venez d'en parler et puis également les
matières premières et notamment la série
les céréales dont la Russie est l'un des
premiers producteurs
Jean-Didier on voit sur des images là
des manifestations à Moscou contre cette
offensive russe en Ukraine comment elle
est perçue justement cette guerre menée
par Vladimir Poutine déjà plusieurs
manifestants ont été arrêtés à
Saint-Pétersbourg notamment
il faut savoir que il se doutait qu'il y
aurait une opération militaire mais il
imaginait plutôt circonscrite aux
alentours du Dombasle le fait que ça
soit sur l'ensemble du territoire
ukrainien on a pris beaucoup de cours et
c'est ce qui s'y opposent sont descendus
dans la rue pour essayer de manifester
mais ils ont été ont dit qu'elle
réprimeraient toute manifestation sans
aucune clémence et c'est pour ça qu'elle
à Moscou les alentours de la place
Pouchkine qui est le lieu symbolique ou
les opposants anti-systèmes et les
partisans avec ses Navalny se réunissent
radissent traditionnellement a été
bouclé en fin d'après-midi les
dispositifs policiers ont été renforcés
à certains endroits clés de la capitale
et
si vous voulez le narratif de la
télévision temps SFR passer la pilule
dans la mesure où on montre
essentiellement des images des
bombardements du dos de basse décrite à
force avec moult détails par les
reporters des chaînes russes qui sont
sur le terrain une façon de discréditer
les autorités ukrainiennes on leur
faisant on les accusant en fait de
persécuter la minorité russophone du
gambas merci beaucoup j'ai envie d'y
revoir en direct
de mots tu as noté qu'on apprend à
l'instant que selon une ONG plus de 700
personnes ont été arrêtées en Russie à
ces manifestations antidaire justement
manifestation qui ont eu lieu également
aujourd'hui à Berlin Paris ou encore
Varsovie et la haie devant des
ambassades russes pour protester contre
cette invasion